What if the ones closest to us the
ones we trusted our whole lives
we're someone else entirely
agent Prescott respectfully
what exactly are you talking about Skrulls
oh come on Ross you know the stories
chaos and
that's only the beginning five Global terrorists
strikes within the past year the atmosphere
has been tense there is an architect to that
tension agent Ross these attacks are escalating
if they hit the soil the major power this didn't
start yesterday it started 30 years ago when the
Skrulls found Earth attacks Colombia Colombia
attacks the Philippines Carol Danvers and Nick
Fury promised to find them a new planet but now
now they don't want just any Planet they want ours
Skrulls could be anybody anywhere anytime and
there is only a tiny handful known to live
on earth that's barely enough to to watch
okay Prescott let's play a little game of
Force for the trees shall we yes Skrulls
can shape-shift yes they're looking for a
new home you'll know God damn I did what
you're talking about Ross but as you say
the only Skrull contact has been through
Nick Fury that means there are allies a
vile and Chain Reaction consuming the globe
you realize that the entire world is at War
and where is Fury he's unsaver yeah and if
I'm gonna bring him down for for whatever the
hell this is I need to give him something
more than just theories I need evidence
all these other attacks compared to this
this is the one that sets the world on fire
let me take this and I'll give the information
to Fury okay that invasion is here Rhodey
and we can't even tell who the Invaders are
this is a ticking time bomb and it was you who
lit the match you're the most wanted man on the
planet well mama always said I was special Fury
in Marvel Studios secret Invasion streaming June
21st only on Disney Plus
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel just released the first
five minutes of secret Invasion Episode One the
series is premiering really soon that's why they
did this big viral marketing campaign there's a
whole bunch of stuff they're setting up in this
clip so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel I'm doing videos for all the
episodes also do a special giveaway during the
episode videos too so be sure to subscribe to
get them all if you didn't see it in your feeds
this morning they were releasing these viral
teasers with this big full Charlie Day meme chart
for like big conspiracy theory chart board and
it's meant to be a version of the one you see in
the opening scene here during the opening scene
you see Everett Ross come back it's been a little
while since the end of the Black Panther wakanda
forever movie I believe we're well into the year
2026 in the MCU at this point they're in Moscow
and he's communicating with the CIA agent on the
DL Val doesn't know about or maybe she does and
she's just letting it happen like she kind of
did that during black panther wakanda forever
because she just arrested him and is probably
keeping tabs on him on the DL but she's got her
own plans I'll explain later but he's still
trying to work with Nick Theory who started
to discover the skrull secret Invasion plot it
seems like a lot of other people haven't figured
it out yet you probably remember Richard Dormer
from Game of Thrones he played Beric dendarian
how many times have you brought me back
it's the Lord of Light brings you back
the closest we get to flaming swords in the MCU
would be kit Harrington's Black Knight character
to make more Game of Thrones references with
the Ebony Blade but technically that doesn't
light on fire it is funny to see a bunch
of Game of Thrones actors especially Emilia
Clarke who's playing Taylor's daughter during
the series show up in the MCU now cannot wait
to see if we'll ever see any crossover between
Amelia Clarke's character and kit Harrington's
Black Knight character don't I remember you from
somewhere have you ever tried to kill me before
and the reason why he's contacting Everett Ross
is because he knows that only a few people have
access to Nick Fury and he's really trying to get
Nick Fury to come on the case come down from the
saber space station the other interesting thing
here too is it makes it sound like the saber space
station itself like the actual space station is
common knowledge amongst the CIA so I'm assuming
this means that Val knows about it too there
haven't really been that many references to
it in the other Marvel movies or the other Marvel
Series so far he's yelling about all these attacks
happening all over the world blaming them on the
skrulls who are pretending to be the different
human terrorist groups but it's just one group
it's just the group of Skrulls they're led by a
character named grabik who's part of the original
group of Skrulls that Talos comes from they're
meant to be good like Skrulls are meant to be
good in general in the MCU but the whole idea
is that this is meant to be a rogue faction from
that same group the big evidence that he gives
to Everett Ross that he claims is big enough to
Warrant Nick Fury wanting to come down from the
saber space station is the larger Skrull plot to
impersonate world leaders probably the president
of the United States big Tipping Point for the
world like this will set the world on fire if
they wind up being successful what would be
worse if they wind up replacing a bunch of the
world leaders the reason he probably tackles him
after ever Ross is like you know what let me look
at this for a little while I'll take it to Nick
Fury is probably just because he's worried that
Everett Ross is also a Skrull during the rest of
the trailer footage you see Nick Fury meeting with
Rhody. Rhody has become the secretary of state
replacing Thunderbolt Ross that's the job that
he had during Captain America Civil War I think
they'll explain what happened with that sometime
during the series I just did a Captain America
4 First Look video because they released a new
teaser they've already recap past the Thunderbolt
Ross character with Harrison Ford so he's meant
to be the same version of Thunderbolt Ross just
a new actor and by the events of Captain America
4 he's supposed to have become the U.S president
but I don't think that that's happening yet like
he hasn't become the president at the beginning
of this series but I think they will explain
what happened to him and how Rhodey became
the new right-hand man to this U.S president
but I think that's the whole reason why Nick
Fury would go to him in not one of the other
Avengers characters because the plot the Skrulls
have involves replacing the U.S president based
on the trailer footage it also seems like the
Skrulls are impersonating Nick Fury to pin some
of the chaos some of the terrorist attacks on him
so the damage control starts coming after him so
that it'll leave them free like he won't be able
to stop the Skrulls from finishing their plot to
take over the world for those of you asking too
because they do reference The Avengers characters
heavily during a lot of these trailers in the
series and they were a big part of the secret
Invasion Arc in the comics maybe they talk
about going to the other Avengers but the
reason why they're busy why they can't help out
is because Hulk just found out about his son scar
are on the car so he's trying to deal with that
doctor strange is in the completely different
dimension he's in the dark dimension with Cleo
dealing with the incursions in the K Multiverse
War leading up to Avengers 5K Dynasty Wong is
still in kamartaj trying to deal with larger
Multiverse problems like the incursions and train
the new initiates Hawkeye is still retired right
now Thor's in a different part of the universe
with Gore's daughter rescuing various alien races
and Captain Marvel is still increased Skrull
space in another part of the universe where
there's this ongoing war of expansion that the
cree have been waging this whole time the only
other characters that would be relevant would be
like Sam Wilson's Captain America and Bucky and
they're basically doing the same thing they were
doing during the Falcon and Winter Soldiers series
like even though he's become the new Captain
America in Bucky's been pardoned by the United
States during Falcon and Winter Soldier episodes
they were basically going on missions just earning
money basically taking down arms dealers dealing
with smaller problems around the globe they're
just continuing to do that so whenever Ross is
like yeah this is business as usual there are
probably problems all over the globe Sam Wilson
and Bucky are still dealing with that stuff like
official above board stuff don't be surprised
though if there are other Avengers cameos and a
lot of references to those characters during the
episodes but one of the biggest new scenes here
is of Emilia Clarke's Gia character entering
this chamber that the evil Skrulls or the bad
faction of Skrulls were building in all the
previous trailers in this abandoned Russian
nuclear power plant they're using the power plant
to power their device here she activates it and
power surrounds her with energy and it looks like
a classic Marvel power upgrade type of scene like
a big glow up power upgrade for her the energy in
the device just evolving her Skrull Powers turning
her into a super Skrull like some of the other
younger generational Skrulls during this one of
the big things that's happening like you see some
of them use their super Skrull powers like this is
graphic the leader of the evil faction of Skrulls
supposedly the younger generation like this evil
faction is trying to turn themselves into Super
schools like give themselves even more powers that
the older generation of Skrulls like the a good
Skrulls talos' group doesn't have making them a
little more like the Skrulls that invaded Earth
during the original comic book secret Invasion
able to actually mimic the powers of the Avengers
the X-Men and their villains and it seems like a
big part of that plot is giving themselves more
powers like turning themselves into Super Skrulls
one of the reported things too there's been a
lot of rumors about Amelia Clarke's character
turning into like a version of comic book Abigail
brand reportedly some of these new powers that she
gains is the ability to create green fire or green
energy kind of like Abigail Brands X-Men powers
in the comics and I think part of the idea during
this like you see her cradling her father talos's
body as he's attacked here I don't know if he's
gonna die but I think part of the idea is that
she'll become Nick Fury's new right-hand person on
this saber space station in sort of like a version
of MCU Abigail brand but she'll just be using that
name as an alias there's been a lot of fan art of
her as Abigail brand obviously she wouldn't look
exactly like this when she's working with Nick
Fury in the future but you kind of get the idea
you get the vibe of the character like the idea
is that she would become a much better bigger
character in the future of the MCU the same way
that Kit Harington Another Game of Thrones alumni
as the Black Knight will become a bigger character
in the future of the MCU everybody just waiting
to hear the Black Knight say that he doesn't want
whatever Gia Emilia Clarke's character is trying
to give him one of the big differences from the
comics though they had this whole plot here where
the Skrulls are trying to give themselves more
Powers evolve themselves into Super Skrulls during
the comic book Invasion the Skrulls that invaded
had the ability to mimic the powers of all of
Earth's Heroes and normally Skrulls don't have
that ability like normal Skrulls only have the
Cosmetic ability to change their form part of
the whole idea though is that secret Invasion
like once everybody learns about the Skrulls
people like Thunderbolt Ross and Val they'll use
that paranoia to their own advantage and gain
positions of power and it's meant to lead into
a dark rain era of Marvel Phase 5 like secret
invasion of the comics led to dark rain like
that happened right after Norman Osborne got
a lot of that storyline but in the MCU I think
they're giving a lot of that to Thunderbolt Ross
and Val Kingpin is also kind of doing his own
version that too becoming mayor of New York
City by the events of Daredevil born again but
the Echo episodes will happen before that like
they just announced that all the echo episodes all
six of them will drop simultaneously in November
Daredevil and Kingpin are really big characters
during that so we'll find out what they're doing
right now and I believe by the end of that like as
we head into the beginning of Daredevil born again
which will happen right after that's where Kingpin
becomes mayor of New York City but the whole idea
the whole vibe with dark rain in Marvel Phase 5
is villains taking positions of power and how to
the heroes like how do the Avengers characters
deal with that there's a bunch of big videos
that I'm working on right now there have been
some cool reports about Avengers 6 Secret Wars
that support some of my theories about the Legacy
Marvel actors coming back again like Toby Maguire
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man the other Legacy X-Men
actors I'll try to finish all those videos as
quickly as possible everyone click here for my
new Iron Man armor Wars teaser video and click
here to learn about how Robert Downey Jr of all
people almost became Doctor Doom of the Marvel
movies thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!